-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well,
and now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
According to estimates from
the Congressional Budget Office,
President Biden's plan to
forgive $10,000 per borrower
in Federal Student loan debt
will cost nearly $400 billion.
Or, in student loan terms,
$27 a month
for 30 billion years.
[ Laughter ]
According to new data,
coronavirus cases
are rising in the U.K.,
maybe because last week,
the entire country
attended the same event.
[ Laughter ]
The White House announced
yesterday that President Biden
will host French President
Emmanuel Macron
later this year.
Which is great, but can we say
no gifts this time?
[ Laughter ]
[ French accent ] "We noticed
you did not have
a 305-foot woman, and..."
[ Laughter ]
"New York famously
has much space, oui?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] That's -- so,
in 2022,
one of our monologue writers
were like, "Enough.
I'm going after
the Statue of Liberty."
[ Laughter ]
Republican Congressman
Matt Gaetz announced last week
that he is starting
his own Twitch
streaming channel, and tweeted,
"I'm joining Twitch to bring
my America-first message to a
new generation of voters."
Previously, the only way
he reached a new generation
of voters was on Venmo.
[ Laughter ]
Scientists recently discovered
vaccine-resistant coronavirus
in Russian bats.
It's what Putin's calling
Plan B.
[ Laughter ]
"Release the bats."
A panel of doctors recommended
last week that all adults
under 65-years-old
should be regularly screened
for anxiety.
Said adults, "How regularly?
Like, once a year?
Once a month?
Every day?
Should we screen every day?
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Rolling Stone" yesterday
published an updated
list of the 100 greatest
TV shows of all-time.
And I don't want to brag,
but I read the whole list.
[ Laughter ]
Not bad, not bad.
100, read 'em all.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
24% of Americans said
that they found it very easy
to make friends as a teenager,
and the other 76%
are the people they bullied.
[ Laughter ]
A woman in North Dakota
was arrested recently
after she allegedly brought
a wild raccoon into a bar.
Said the woman, "Oh, I thought
you said it was rabies night."
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
So, the premise of Brian --
I'll say his name --
the premise of Brian's joke...
[ Laughter ]
...is that you would hear a bar
was having "ladies night"
and you would hear it
as "rabies night."
[ Laughter ]
Maybe that's a symptom
that you have rabies.
[ Laughter ]
You're home
with your pet raccoon,
and it bites you, and then,
like, an hour later,
you're like,
"Did I hear rabies night?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally --
we just let 'em all in, guys.
We're just finding out with you
if they're good or not,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according
to a new survey,
78% of animal owners said
that seeing their pet
when they come home is the best
part of their day.
Worst part of their day,
when their spouse
heard them say that.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.